for nearly 20 years the Cassini  spacecraft operates to perfection with  stunning scientific results  [Music]  moons are everywhere you look from rocks  about 1/3 of a mile across to one almost  the size of Mars  [Music]  a flyby of the ice moon enceladus Attili  changes the game  the heat discovered at Enceladus  suggests that could be hydrothermal  vents under its ocean floor similar  features on earth are known to harbor  life here is this tiny world with the  liquid water ocean underneath its icy  crust with the possibility of  hydrothermal vents on its seafloor so  you have all the key ingredients for  life water the source of energy and  nutrients coming from the hydrothermal  vents  [Applause]  these are Cassini's final hours of life  and still it gathers data right up to  the end  [Music]